si elles ne sont pas déjà vides elles
sont prises d'assaut par les
automobilistes en france depuis dimanche
les stations services affichent des
files interminables de conducteurs venus
faire le plein à magny les hameaux cette
station disposait encore de quelques
réserves ce matin mais ne tiendra pas la
journée on a un afflux de clients
qui engendre de
une certaine pénurie au niveau des
approvisionnements et ensuite le
problème qu'on a c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
n'est pas livré et c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu pénible dans le sens
où on va on va se retrouver en rupture
de
différents carburants en milieu voire en
fin d'après-midi une situation en france
provoquée par le blocage de huit
raffineries et de plusieurs dépôts par
la cgt l'origine de ces blocages le
retrait de la loi travail demandé au
gouvernement par le syndicat il faut
pouvoir bloquer le pays pour que ça
avance
il va bien falloir que quelque chose qui
fait d'un côté ou de l'autre et le
gouvernement étant tellement arc bouté
sur surnom n'enlèvera rien et avec cette
extrême violence de l'avoir fait passer
par 49,3 qu' il faut bien que le monde
du travail des salariés répondent un
bras de fer entre le gouvernement et le
syndicat que daniel guerreau président
de l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes dénonce que chacun
prenne ses responsabilités c'est quand
même pas normal
enfin on est sur un bras de fer comme ça
on doit pouvoir se parler on va pas
retrouver les solutions et surtout
éviter qu'une grande population l'écart
notre vie sera là comme système pour
faire plier
je dirais des gens qui sont pas d'accord
entre eux une situation qui a créé un
vent de panique chez les conducteurs
aller faire le plein par peur de manquer
le meilleur moyen de contribuer à la
pénurie et à la pompe
on prend son mal en patience ils ont
bien raison
ils ont bien raison quelque part
malheureusement c'est le seul moyen de
se faire entendre actuellement parce que
je trouve dommage c'est que des gens qui
fassent des réserves après bon on a tous
besoin de carburant donc c'est un peu
légitime quoi certaines stations ont
même choisi l'option de rationner leurs
clients limitant la quantité d'essence
par personne en milieu de journée
environ 40 % des stations-service de
france étaient en pénurie totale ou
partielle